Our next guest is the mother of two and she created a line
of masks for the whole family,
and we're so happy that she did,
and we're so happy that she's here.
From supermodel to supermom,
please welcome Karolina Kurkova.
(audience applauds)
Hi.
Hello.
How are you, Drew?
I'm really good, and I wanted to jump right in
by showing you two pictures of me.
I took them this weekend in honor of you being here,
and I have to tell you,
I have been wearing this mask nonstop.
Now, obviously nobody knew masks would be a thing this year,
but you and Billie Blooms have elevated them
to not only a real fashion accessory,
but every time I wear it, I feel like I'm blowing a kiss.
It's, they're just really incredible quality
and they're optimistic and beautiful.
How did this all start?
Well, thank you so much for saying so many nice things
about the masks.
Really. When we started with my friend, Ashley Liemer,
back in early April,
we really wanted to do something that was giving back
and to our community and to people, you know,
that were losing jobs, including Ashley's seamstresses
that she's been working with for over 15 years,
that, you know, suddenly she had to let go.
And we really have, being moms,
we knew we wanted to create masks that really were happy,
that were fashionable, that were fun and different,
and really make it a little bit more fun and easier
for people to wear them, especially for children.
You know, how do you tell a three-year-old,
"Oh, now suddenly you have to wear these masks,"
which you know, they're not so comfortable.
Yes, you do get hot underneath them,
and so we really worked really hard.
How can we make them more comfortable?
How can we make them more fun?
And so we did embroidery of cats and a dog,
which is our cat, Kaja, and dog, Bowie.
And we gave it also a story
to kind of turn this mask-wearing around
from being something that's like so hard and difficult.
It's, you know what?
You are a superhero,
and even superheroes don't just wear capes,
but they wear masks to protect the people
that they love around them.
Can I come join your family?
Because you are an amazing mom.
And that is the type of rhetoric and words, words matter.
They are everything to me.
And it is so unique to find a new language
about everything this year and how we empower our kids
and how we make them aware and responsible,
but keep it not scary, and joyful
is one of the most original, unique, difficult, tightropes
we will ever walk in our lifetime.
And I just have to say that I think
what you are doing is profoundly important
and they're excellent masks.
I put them in the little yellow book this week.
I am in love with these,
and I'm so grateful for you to do what you are doing.
And we here on the show really celebrate it.
Thank you Karolina, for being an amazing woman,
an amazing mom, and now making a product that truly works
in every single way.
Thank you.
And also, I forgot to mention that from every mask
that's purchased from us, proceeds goes to Feeding America.
And that really was really important for us,
really just giving back and keeping families safe,
and thank you, thank you.
It's been really an incredible journey
and to have something, you know,
during times where it has been so confusing
and you're at home,
and especially when everything started to feel so helpless,
you know, I'm not a doctor, Ashley's not a doctor.
We felt like we wanted to do something.
And really this project gave us so much joy and creativity
and have our families and our children being part
of creating these masks for other children and, you know,
being our models and test models.
And it's been really incredible, you know,
and now it's our new accessory and, you know,
keeping us safe and keeping it fun.
And beautiful. Thank you, Karolina.
Billieblooms.com.
(happy, laidback music)